[Music]
the shimmer is sort of phenomenon they
don't know what's happened to all of the
people who have gone in and kind of come
back
it is moving so quickly and soon it's
just gonna be devouring cities and
things and they just don't have any idea
what it is I need to know what's inside
and she decides to volunteer on the next
mission as we go in we start discovering
that things are just mutating more
mutations they're everywhere
sort of creepy things happening are they
understand they're no they're terrifying
it's really theory this used to be the
headquarters as a southern reach before
the shimmer swallowed it for those that
follow me
the soldiers on the last expedition they
went crazy or something in here kill
them there was some chilling
I definitely think annihilation is
something we haven't seen quite yet
offense can you describe his fault no
stop from the beginning what do you
think I do when you're away you think
I'm out in the garden pining looking up
at the sky
why are you here I gotta leave a day
early your husband's here let me see him
he was extremely ill you have to tell me
where he was what he was doing it was
his decision to go in
it's something they termed the shimmer
we've sent in drones in teams of people
but nothing comes back but something has
you're a biologist who served in the
military if I knew what happened I could
save his life
the boundary is getting bigger it's
expanding we're talking city-states you
need to know what's inside it's
beautiful
check this out looks like they're stuck
in a continuous mutation I understand
they're no sharks have teeth like that
it's not possible you can't cross great
different species
yes the soldiers on the last expedition
it's not crazy or something here kill
them something's come to the fence
you're the fence we have to go back I
can't go back
we can camp here tonight
it's destroying everything it's not
destroying
it's making something new
[Music]
[Music]
you